okay let's talk about the California
gubernatorial recall the California
gubernatorial recall is today there are
basically two possibilities either the
don't recall the keep Gavin Newsom side
wins and Gavin Newsom Remains the
Democratic governor of California an
overwhelmingly Democratic state or or
the remove Gavin Newsom sidewinds and
almost certainly an outrageous
right-wing extremist named Larry Elder
becomes the pro-trump
anti-vax anti-mask governor
of California really horrible stuff
we'll get to how it's looking in a
moment last night Joe Biden actually was
in California and he did an event in
support of Gavin Newsom Ron philipkowski
doing a great job with his team covering
the Riff Raff outside the event he has
teams at all of these different events
filming check out this is just to give
you like the flavor of what's going on
this is just another argument between
you know there's anti-vaxxers there's
all sorts of wacky people showing up and
check just listen to the arguments that
are taking place here if you can
never mind
notice what's going on here there's two
different arguments going on in front of
an F Joe Biden sign it's it's just
complete in total chaos
hundreds of thousands
in less than one year now the audio
glitched but I think Air Force mom
unmasked Air Force mom is yelling that
there have been hundreds of thousands of
deaths from the vaccine is that what
she's saying less than one Year
sweetheart
dude how many people die from the flu
vaccine in one year have you looked it
up she's saying more people died from
the vaccine than the flu I guess
[Laughter]
why
why do I can't you have an immune system
so that's Air Force mom screaming there
the proud boys also had a presence at
this event this is a short clip uh if
you're not watching the the proud boys
are are you know walking with a huge
Banner it's just all it's all nuts
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
the banner says free all political
prisoners now which is a reference
basically they're saying free all of the
rioters who were arrested on January 6th
they want those they want the
insurrectionists freed
[Applause]
om saluting now what are they doing
there's a police line
someone just yelled Communists there
and these are the last places I would be
caught it's just it's crazy then they
went back to Air Force mom like a while
later and the argument was still going
on with anti-vax air force mom
ENT
so this is like uh oh my God what does
sociological experiment so if you've
just been listening to this these people
arguing
on the left slash kind of like in the
background you've got unmasked
unvaccinated Air Force mom telling a
woman that more people died from the
vaccine than from the flu in the last
year that's of course not true then in
the foreground you have another woman
saying that the Gavin knew some if Gavin
Newsom stays in the taxes will break
California now remember
um California has one of the most
dynamic economies in the world if
California were a country it would be
growing almost as quickly as many really
quickly growing developing nations
there's a homelessness problem without a
doubt it's not affordable for everyone
but one of the things that makes places
expensive is demand people want to be
there and it drives the prices of things
up so two wacky arguments happening at
the exact same time
illegal immigrants have more rights than
so the xenophobia gets thrown into
evening
yeah
okay well but how much do you make what
percentage is that okay so the important
thing is the recall is today today today
if you haven't voted yet you've got to
vote mail in that ballot the good news
is that after in early August it was
basically tied okay it was basically
tied in early August Gavin Newsom has
built a lead that is now 16 points now
does that mean we don't vote of course
not it means you've got to go vote
you've got to go vote results are
expected around 8 P.M California time
tonight tonight 11 p.m eastern time I
will be streaming I will be streaming up
until we get those first results and I
hope that you will join me uh
unfortunately unfortunately or maybe
predictably Larry Elder the Republican
can't the leading Republican candidate
is not committed to accepting the
results if he loses let's talk about
that next one of our sponsors is sheath
underwear it is the hottest part of the
year right now if you're a guy who wears
traditional underwear you know about the
sticking and the rubbing and the chafing
not something you have to worry about
with sheath underwear which is designed
with multiple ergonomic compartments in
the front which prevent skin on skin
contact keeping everything separate dry
cool and comfortable sheath actually
just re-released to limited edition
Styles the Flower of Life featuring a
stylish enamoring flower pattern and
bold the geometric waistband the other
limited edition style is the mesh
airflow specially designed to be
lightweight and promote extra coolness
and breathability sheath underwear was
designed by an Iraq war veteran who was
looking for a way to keep himself dry
and comfortable in the hot desert and
the underwear he developed ended up
being perfect for just about any context
in everyday use sheath underwear is
giving my viewers 20 off when you go to
sheathunderwear.com Pacman and use the
promo code Pacman